this week on quadriga egyptian disaster
international failure
the situation in egypt remains tense
after the army's suppression of protests
by muslim brotherhood supporters
the military blames pro-morsi forces for
initiating the violence and is calling
its crackdown a war on terror
the european union and the u.s are
concerned in a bid to force the army
into negotiations the eu has now agreed
to freeze weapon sales to egypt
can the west influence the course of
events
or is a rollback inevitable your host
this week melinda crane
hello and welcome to quadriga who lost
egypt that's the question being posed in
many western capitals this week but how
much leverage did outside countries ever
really have
and what influence can they exercise now
those are two of the questions we want
to talk about with three journalists and
filmmakers who've been following events
in egypt very closely and they are
thomas hazel he's a german journalist
and political scientist an expert on the
arab world who's taught courses on north
african democratization at berlin's free
university and he's recently produced
documentaries on post-mubarak egypt
alan posner was born in london grew up
in malaysia and in germany he's an
influential blogger he contributes to
the magazine the european and he's
written for the german newspaper
developed he's authored numerous books
including an appeal for europe to begin
acting like a true world power
and finally we're very pleased to
welcome yazmina
she is a german iraqi freelance
journalist now based here in germany and
filming a documentary on libyan wounded
living in germany but she lived in egypt
with her egyptian husband until 2011.
so welcome to all of you glad you could
be on the show this week yes
let's start out with a look at what
appears to be a very major divergence in
perceptions within egypt as opposed to
perceptions in the west apparently many
egyptians continue to feel that all the
force although the force used was
excessive the military did need to take
action against the muslim brotherhood
and their supporters how do you see it
and what are you hearing from family in
egypt these days
actually the egyptian military has
committed a big mistake by leaving the
muslim brotherhood protest like this in
dawia and in another if they would have
from the very beginning put a couple of
borders on the way of protesting not
letting the people living and causing
chaos there it would be have much easier
for them to
be a part of a democratic movement but
in this time people lost their faith in
muslim brotherhood rather than they had
before some people who elected the
muslim brotherhood are not against them
and are even supporting the military
regime and in terms of your own family
and friends in egypt what are they
saying are they distressed about the
situation do they feel that the military
did take the right action what opinions
are you hearing there for sure they say
that they committed a mistake by taking
that much force on the protesters but at
the same time they say that they had to
take action because otherwise the
country would have fallen in a bigger
case that they are actually suffering
from right now
thomas hassel in some ways what we're
seeing in terms of this
divergence egyptian majority perceptions
and the perception in the west seems to
bear out that old adage that one man's
freedom fighter is another man's
terrorist
we see a huge radicalization in in the
speech in egypt we have um people who
are uh on different sides now and uh
they define the other as really a
terrorist as an opponent to god things
like this there are big words that
people use now to describe the other the
the political um opponent and this is
this is the dangerous um
cycle we have now uh we have this
radicalization of speech we have this
radicalization on the street with a lot
of dead people now with a lot of people
killed and
the difficult thing is that we have this
split in society in groups of friends in
families um where you have one side
saying what the military did was right
the muslim brotherhood is a terrorist
organization uh they had to save egypt
in a way and the other side saying um no
the muslim brotherhood did not so bad or
they said well they did not so good but
you shouldn't act like this
on them and a lot of people are fearing
that the military will use the situation
to strengthen its own role others are
welcoming the military and hoping that
the military will lead um the society to
a more democratic path and there's a lot
of discussion and conflict about this
the generals alan posner have been
framing the whole situation as a choice
basically between stability or anarchy
and some in other countries seem to
support that point of view we heard an
israeli spokesman this week saying look
it's either the army or anarchy is he
right do you think
he's probably right i mean we've we've
heard voices of people who know uh egypt
much better than i do um
but you know this is egypt is important
because it's the only state in the
region um in the arab world which is
which has existed within these borders
for so long it's not a you know it's not
a it's not a state like syria which has
been drawn on a map by european colonial
powers after dissolving of the ottoman
empire it's a it's a it's a very
important pillar of stability
and i do have the feeling that mostly
showed in his year in power that he
intended you know his idea was one man
one vote one time we've seen what his
you know his comp he's you know his
allies the hamas did in gaza same thing
they won an election yes they didn't
haven't let anyone
vote since then so and and half the
egyptian population were against morsi
by the time the army stepped in there
was going to be
big time civil war if something didn't
happen you say
egypt is not like syria but many people
yasmine al-ghanavi are now worried that
it could become like syria there is talk
about that anarchy taking egypt into
civil war do you think that's a real
possibility well if you look at egyptian
history never see that there was any
potential of a civil war like there was
or there is in syria and other arabic
countries like for example iraq or and
anything similar to this because the
egyptian on the one hand are okay
against uh the leadership of muslim
brotherhood by the same time you see
more than half of the population
supporting the military by taking action
the at the same time they learned from
the past mistakes they won't allow a
second hosni mubarak coming up but in
the same time they need someone as you
said leaving the path to democracy and
they there won't be a
right leader as long as there is no one
who can lead the path and they need the
military to lead the path
i disagree i may say um i don't think
that the military in egypt has any
interest
in a real genuine democratization they
showed in the past in the past decades
in the past two years and now again that
they um that they try to block any
democratization if you look at the new
uh constitution that people work upon
right now um it shows no sign of any
democratization ongoing there's no
improvement in the in the constitution
except that religious parties uh have to
be checked and it's not easy to to uh to
uh establish a religious party anymore
the rest is really if you look at the
the points strengthen the military role
um hindering a real uh the real
development of a party society or party
politics um
i i don't see any sign of a path to
democracy the only people who can
work for democracy other people itself
and those who were against the coup or
the the the downfall of mursi in the way
it was done um
and those who were still opposed to the
muslim brotherhood yeah i mean there are
people it's called the third way now in
egypt where against the military
controlling the country and against the
muslim brotherhood controlling the
country of course was not a democratic
party it was
uh it hadn't been an easy task but it
was uh dealing like some group that knew
that that when they get away from power
they come back to prison so they they
didn't work together with people and
they behaved in a really bad way of
course i don't think that the military
has learned from its own mistakes by
letting
a leader for decades or leaders for
decades leading the country from the
military i think that the military has
learned itself that they can't force the
will on the population that the
population will take action if a second
mubarak or if a second
person like
cece would come up and say i
will now lead the country because i
think that the egyptian people learned
and the military has learned in the same
time if you let all these groups these
these undemocratic groups without
calling their names of
certain parties um they need a kind of
of role of so that they learn how to
take um the possibility of a discussion
because what egyptians have to uh has
have to know uh to learn now is the
possibility of discussion they didn't
have the possibility of discussion
before this is the reason why they only
learned that democracy can be taken by
force but one of the questions if you're
just permitting me to jump in one of the
questions of course is the degree to
which they really have that possibility
to discuss now we listened to a few
voices from egypt and took a look at
what the media there are saying let's
take a look
egypt's armed forces have detained a
number of senior muslim brotherhood
figures in recent days including the
organization's supreme leader mohammed
badiya
egyptians remain deeply divided about
the military's actions
the arrests of the leaders will create
more violence
now the streets will start to calm down
and violence will subside and there will
be no problems
the situation in egypt does not work we
are afraid we are collectively depressed
we don't know what to do
the country's media no longer reflects
this spectrum of opinion
state and private channels are largely
following the army's lead
foreign news outlets are coming under
pressure
does this spell the end of egypt's
experiment with democracy
what do you think ellen postner thomas
has just referred to the third way
groups within society that are neither
sympathizers of the muslim brotherhood
nor of the military but how much room do
they have to develop and to try to get a
democratic debate going in a culture
where the media apparently have been
completely brought back to a party line
yeah well i'm neither an expert in egypt
nor am i
do i have a crystal ball to look in the
future but it seems to me that what
happens in these situations this is a
counter-revolutionary
situation um
and that what happens is the military
always overreacts or the you know if
it's the white guards in russia whoever
it is you know if it's pinochet in chile
so for
i think for the time being we have to
accept that there's going to be a huge
clamp down and and there's not going to
be a
democracy in egypt and to sort of
let's consider the worst case i think
the worst case is going to happen um but
it should we should at least not kid
ourselves yeah i really think what we're
looking at now is a kind of
reinstatement of the mubarak regime
i mean he he's going to use some more
islamist phrases um you know to gain
support from that quarter and he's maybe
going to pretend to have a sort of
sort of putiness kind of democracy but
you know let's not be fooled by that yes
we're hearing that mubarak is going to
be released perhaps to house arrest but
he is going to be released from prison
we're also hearing questions about the
loyalty of muhammad al-baradi the nobel
prize winner who had been vice president
in the regime and just stepped down to
protest the military action
a regime that is capable of those two
things do you really trust it to bring
egypt
onto a democratic traffic path i didn't
say that i support the intervening of of
the military that i think that they but
they need a guidance
how can they be guided to to a
possibility to discuss because at the
moment either the liberals and the
muslim brotherhood are not ready to
discuss with each other so there has to
be someone a force or power or whatever
that can bring them to one table to to
to discuss with each other to force them
to discuss because there won't be in
egypt without the islamist force they
have to be part of the democrat uh the
new egypt of the democratic egypt and
there won't be a new egypt without the
liberal part so the liberal party is
also to be part of the new democratic
egypt in the same time the tamarrod
youth that has also been in the tahrir
square and protesting and also the third
way that thomas has talked about yeah
well some of them also support the the
intervenings of the military so well
actually most of them do so um the third
part the third row there are the normal
egyptians who really want to move on
with their lives because actually egypt
especially for normal egyptians is stuck
there is nothing moving on no no economy
no nothing there it's stuck it's still
on the same way like two years ago
thomas let's talk briefly uh about where
the muslim brotherhood might be headed
to this point you have done some writing
on algeria which was a country that set
a precedent by overturning a democratic
election when an islamic party came to
power to what degree are islamists like
the muslim brotherhood capable of
playing a democratic role or is it
simply
excluded from the start
i don't think it's excluded i think
to be
part of a democratic
process can also be learned as you said
citizens have to learn to behave like
citizens or people have to to learn uh
to behave like citizens in a democracy
parties can learn this as well or groups
can learn this as well and this is a
process that takes takes time but it's
it's not it's not supported by um
stopping a political process uh one year
after the election for example that's
that's quite a problem right and and to
to uh to dissolve the parliament and to
to bring the president morsi down is
from a process of a democratization a
bad step what do you think that it will
mean for the brotherhood would you
suppose that it will create more
extremism and jihadism or are they
likely to go back to the kind of role
they had in the mubarak area
i think it's
it's
if you talk about algeria or other
countries as well you have always the
problem that you have some kind of
leadership that is somebody you can talk
to that can moderate um their um
the radicals in in their own group and
if they are put into prison or somehow
taken out of the of the game then you
have the young or the radical part left
this means mostly radicalization that
what happened in algeria all the
leadership was was put into prison um
people were killed as well and then
people got radical and more radical and
we had at the end around
200 000 dead people i think this will
not happen to egypt because i think the
muslim brotherhood wouldn't act this way
but the question is can they control
people who
would take arms yeah this is the this is
the question but on the other hand i
think in algeria it was possible for the
military to
let this killing happen because the
elite and the military was um well saved
by the oil and and gas rich richest
wealth they have in egypt this is not
possible some kind of civil civil war
like this
would lead to total case and in the end
perhaps even to interference by foreign
powers because egypt is too important
strategically for israel as
as host of the suez canal
egypt can never plunge into a civil war
this could not happen strategically for
the western world
yasmina aganavi just told us that
many people in egypt the normal
egyptians simply want to get on with
their lives alan posner and their lives
are of course
very much hampered at the moment by
economic misery and so on
the fact is the new york times had a
rather amusing article today from egypt
saying that
the main people out ontario square
talking about the situation were western
journalists and that the egyptians they
were asking basically um didn't really
express much interest in talking about
this subject there has been an immense
western media outcry since uh since the
military took action
yet the official reaction in most
western countries has been rather
ambivalent what do you think
does the west need to take stronger
action and if so what might it achieve
quite frankly i don't see what we can
achieve i mean the european union has
now cancelled military aid at least
military that can be used to oppress the
people look our military aid is less
than 7 million a year the united states
has 1.3 billion a year there you see the
dimension so so what can they do but
even if the united states canceled
military aid the
egyptian government has already said
we'll get the money from saudi arabia
we'll buy the stuff in russia and putin
will be only too willing this is the old
cold war situation to step in where the
united states steps out so what can we
do you tell me i don't see really that
we can do anything that wouldn't
exacerbate the situation we this is
really a situation where you see the
limits of any kind of power hard power
anyway but even soft power
everybody's nodding yes
would you like to see the eu for
starters take stronger action they did
say that they're going to review
economic aid but that they will not cut
it off if it is directed towards civil
society and the fact is that most
economic aid from europe is directed
towards civil society so not much room
for movement there then there's the
military aid that alan posner talked
about some change on that perhaps but
nothing very dramatic is it enough
i don't think so i i i totally agree
with you because even if the european
union would cut off the aid totally
saudi arabia and qatar officially said
we will support egypt we will give egypt
the money that it needs
so what really surprises me is actually
that saudi arabia and qatar are
interested in kind of a democratic
movement in egypt that's
so
i don't are they it seems but i i don't
agree with it
no but what i'm saying is that um qatar
officially supported the muslim
brotherhood and now qatar is ready to
support the military government in egypt
which is a total movement so what kind
of interests are there hidden this is
the more interesting question that keeps
on making qatar changing their mind in a
very short time well actually crises can
create kind of funny bedfellows can't
they thomas hazel if we look at the fact
that saudi arabia is saying things that
sound very much like israel
well yeah i mean it's um if you get away
from the internal affairs let's say in
egypt and you look at the geopolitical
structure of this region
we have strange bad followers indeed and
if you look at the interests of israel
saudi arabia qatar the u.s russia et
cetera et cetera we have syria which is
a very important issue um you see that
that
suddenly you have the same interests on
sides that were before split apart like
saudi arabia and israel of course they
are somehow
always fighting about the palestinian
issue in words at least
but reality is for israel it's very
important as a stable egypt and an egypt
which is not attacking them menacing
them and which keeps the peace treaty in
a certain way maybe there will be some
talk in the future about the peace
treaty of the 70s but um
israel wants strong military
is a counter-revolutionary egypt to use
alan posner's term a stable egypt
that's that will be uh remains to be
seen i'm not sure about this but i i i
imagine that the military in egypt is
able to somehow contain radicalization
and the important thing for israel i
think is at the moment that the sinai
becomes much more stable than it was
right now and we have had this link
between murasi and the hamas movement
for example something that the military
in egypt didn't like so much and the
israelis couldn't like so much and so
this link is now um
has come to an end of course i could
just add
sinai was never a stable place in egypt
not in mubarak area no before it was
never a stable part of egypt so you also
always had the movement of the clients
over there between egypt and and
palestine and
it was never a stable place but it has
become much more unstable i would say in
the last um two years so that's what we
see
that's what we see in here in europe
alan posner i think the the elephant in
the room of course is is iran because
that's the reason uh i'm by the way why
the europeans
are supporting saudi arabia giving them
tanks i mean it's crazy we're cutting
off
our feeble military aid to egypt but
we're still supporting egypt's back as
saudi arabia with tanks why are we doing
this because we are afraid that iran
will want um to dominate the gulf area
which we are dependent on for our oil
it's not the united states anymore
that's dependent they have their own
shale gas we are dependent on that
that's why um the european union is sort
of pussyfooting around here because
uh you know saudi arabia egypt uh israel
they all want iran to be kept out of the
equation
allen posner you wrote a book as i
mentioned at the outset uh calling on
europe to start acting like a world
power finally is it doing so here in
this situation
no
and um
europe has been been uh
been
caught up with its own woes the past
three four years the euro so-called euro
crisis um and and we've been inward
looking for all this time we've let the
arab spring pass us by um we
we didn't do anything to encourage uh
the arab spring if you remember the
first french reaction to what happened
in tunisia was let's support the
dictator there i mean we've behaved
terribly and we're in in in no condition
in to really influence affairs there
it's really we also
let turkey slip out of uh our our reach
which could have acted as some kind of
um model for a development of the muslim
brotherhood towards some kind of
democracy but what the opposite now has
happened now mr adawan seems to be
copying the muslim brotherhood it's it's
a terrible tragedy as far as europe is
concerned thomas has a whole parade of
european diplomats passed through cairo
in the past six to eight weeks and
indeed before that as well trying to put
pressure on mr marcy all of it to no
avail
i want to add one thing about european
influence in the region i think what is
really very difficult and we see it
again and again in the libyan case two
years ago we saw it as well if you have
a policy for decades
um to deal with dictators or
authoritarian regimes out of some kind
of rationale that it's strategically
economically important to do that
and then you have people who are um
fighting against
the condition of life and against these
dictators europe of course has some kind
of problem because uh our ethoric means
or our values are democracy human rights
et cetera
and not um
oppressing human rights and democracy
because we are economically or
strategically bound to this region so we
always have this problem but supposedly
europe is actually viewed with more
neutrality or goodwill in in many cases
as the u.s catherine ashton for example
was permitted to go to the prison where
morsi is being held
you don't think europe has slightly
better cards to play
i think we deceive ourselves we think
that i mean there's a certain time when
um europe and the arab world has not all
of europe let's say because england and
or great britain and france have a
colonial history of course they have
different links to the region than
germany has for example yeah there are
but but there is a time when when europe
can play a certain role but these are
softer times let's say yeah or in the
background with secret services they can
deal somehow but
to go now and say um
if you don't democratize or if you don't
let this and this happen we will stop
our aid this doesn't help much i would
say
the biggest aid package yasmina agunabi
of course is the one that comes from the
u.s 1.3 billion in military support and
a whole lot of economic development aid
as well
so far the u.s has done a whole lot of
hands-ringing but not much more what
would you like to see the u.s do
well i actually would think that it
won't even bring much if the us would
interfere more because if you really the
western world like the european union
and the us are interested in having
democracy in such countries like tunisia
egypt and and libya they would have
interfered a long time before it was in
their interest that gaddafi would stay
for 40 years that benalli would stay for
30 years so that mubarak would stay for
over 30 years so it wasn't their
interest so they can come over and say
well we're actually interested in in
democracy in the region this is the
reason why we take cut off our in our
economic support if you don't
democratize
how discredited would you say that the
u.s is in the region supposedly
everybody's angry at the u.s is that
true well actually a lot of people don't
even care that much as i mean the the
the people who i have talked to at least
they say well they can't say anything i
mean if they come over and say we'll cut
off the eights okay we'll get our money
from saudi arabia and from qatar that's
it so it's that easy for the people
because they're really interested in
moving on they're no longer interested
in fighting between each other it's more
like fighting of powers between the
muslim brotherhood and the military at
the moment but the normal egyptians are
only interested in moving on having
their lives
and going back to work and that's it
to what degree is that promise of
filling in for any u.s european deficit
by saudi arabia and qatar
really a major difference in the
situation there was quite a persuasive
article in the new york times this week
alan posner by
a political scientist who said look
american presidents way back to clinton
have tried to use aid to
make egyptian rulers govern differently
and it's never worked neither with
clinton nor with bush so is it really
about that saudi promise or is it simply
about the fact that our leverage over
other countries domestic politics is
very limited
well it's both um
and and it goes back even further
because in the cold war uh any dictator
you didn't like could turn to the
russians the soviet side and get uh help
from them uh so you were always in this
bind that uh you know your u.s policies
has never really this idea that the
united states controls what happens you
know the cia topless governments here
does this there you know it happened you
know occasionally but basically
always it's always been limited and you
know when the united states actually
tried you know when the neocons were an
ascendancy and tried to export democracy
to iraq and i think one lesson the
united states learned from that is we're
not going to do that again i mean you
can argue
whether that wasn't actually a success
i mean iraq is
comparatively democratic comparatively
stable compared to most of the rest of
the arab world but whatever you say
about it the americans do not want to
repeat that experience and everyone
knows that let's not argue about iraq
right now because it will hijack our
program but thomas hazel
it seems like i'm hearing from everybody
here um
our hands are tied there's not a lot we
can do
would you take that point of view and
would you even take it if the violence
and repression get worse
i mean i think we have to differentiate
the internal things in egypt now with
the regional or strategic importance of
the region i think
our the western let's say politics in
this region is problematic all the time
i mean it is problematic because of
reasons we need this region we need the
energy we need strategically uh certain
certain ways the seuss canal etc israel
is very important for germans as well
like for the americans so this is always
the major concern we have in this region
and a certain stability of course yeah
um so democratization or human rights as
nice as they are as important as they
are for us
as values are not the utmost thing for
for
governments in in the west so i think um
there should be really talk about the
whole region and the question how do we
deal in the future with iran and the
gulf area is it does it really make
sense if germany sells so many weapons
to qatar to saudi arabia to even fill
more weapons there weapons that are then
maybe brought or money that is brought
afterwards to egypt and we criticize
that i mean it's somehow strange it goes
around corners so i think
the same for syria there must be there
should be in an ideal world a big
discussion or really a big solution for
the whole area
and maybe then we also have to say
goodbye to some privileges we as europe
have economical privileges i think this
is the issue here um if we don't do that
we will always have these crises and
they will be going on and on and this
solution now or what's happening on
egypt will not solve any problem it will
be a new kind of
semi-autocratic system maybe some civil
uh
civil government will be there the
military will be unharmed will uh will
guarantee the stability in the region
but that's it the people have nothing
the people are poor you have 40 percent
of people in egypt that are really poor
if you go to farm
little farmers if you go to the poor
areas in cairo or in upper egypt people
have nothing and that's not just the
muslim brotherhood they couldn't do
anything in one year it's 40 50 years of
bad governance of of an elite neglecting
these people and they have nothing they
have nothing in their hands now and i
don't think this will change
the neoliberal let's say
direction egypt is heading or was
heading all the time
is unchanged and that's a sad thing for
the people i think yes
bearing that poverty in mind there is
ongoing negotiation between egypt and
the international monetary fund about a
big
loan to try to address some of the
major economic problems that egypt has
encountered since morsi took power
would that
offer any leverage
that could probably possibly effect
constructive change
well
egypt needs more than that because it's
not only as you said the power
regions in egypt that is poor it's not
only upper egypt it's also what we
called here in europe the social media
class because there is no longer a
social media class people who were
employed by the government like for
example the family of my husband
they're becoming poorer and poorer what
they had well they had the opportunity
before to save money but right now they
have to count their money how they're
going to live
until the end of the month
and they have
like my brother-in-law has four children
send them to school it costs money so
it's not only the poor regions so a lot
like that
will kind of be
a small help but egypt needs bigger help
and especially when you have the ngos
it needs support from ngos
ellen posner can we expect a regime that
looks very much like the old mubarak
regime led by the military which of
course had a huge economic stake
in egypt can we really expect a regime
like that to institute the sort of
economic reforms that could change that
situation i doubt it very much for the
reason you said that they the military
themselves there's a military industrial
or military economic complex and they
have corrupted uh also a lot of the
so-called middle class which aren't
really middle class their people are
working for them it's um like the saudis
have corrupted their people with oil
money and so on
because you know sometimes you get a
military coup which horrible as it is
turns out to be a good thing like
pinochet in chile at the end of the
pinochet regime you had a middle class
which was capable and wanted democracy
will the you know if will the egyptian
military who basically are the same
people who were there before will they
force their own clientele to give up
their privileges i doubt it but this is
the only way forward uh for egypt i
don't know if europe on the united
states is any kind or or the world bank
for that matter any kind of leverage
give them money and it all goes to the
same canals it always has gone through
and enriches precisely the people who
aren't interested in giving up their
privileges i mean that's really you need
a social revolution whether from the top
of from the bottom
yes
just mentioned what is sometimes
referred to as soft power the attempt to
work with
groups in civil society with young
people you've done some of that thomas
hazel can that make a difference in this
situation
i mean it's always important to have a
civil society that's alive that has some
space to work that is not um
uh not in danger to be put in prison or
to be oppressed by some state people um
because they do what they do um this
space
we value so much in democratic societies
is is not there in egypt was not there
in egypt for a very long time it was
growing in the last two years then was
narrowed down again by the muslim
brotherhood and we have to see if now
the military
is a wise military and will
it will allow certain
freedoms in this country because
the majority of the people
are young people and there are very
talented young people energetic young
people and they have so many ideas they
want to change their country to better
but will they have the space whenever i
talk to people to young entrepreneurs in
in egypt they were saying you know if we
want to establish a company we have to
go to the state bureaucracy and they
hinder us in any step we want to take
it's so difficult and other people told
me the reason why this is they have six
million um
civil servants they have people from the
army mostly heading these agencies and
these army people mostly want to control
what's going on right and so instead of
saying yeah do whatever you want the
american way do if you fail no matter
try it now they say no it's a problem if
you want to do something you need so
many papers and so many paperwork
everyone's asking what are you doing is
this dangerous and this mentality would
have to change totally it's a very
military thinking hierarchy orders to
give and people obey and this is not
working for a free democrat free free
market system this would have to change
um i think this is the most important
thing
yes
i myself did some media training and
civil society work with young egyptians
at the very end of the mubarak era many
of them simply wanted to leave the
country
what is the situation now after all this
happened
where do you see young people's thoughts
about their own future
well to talk about my contacts
mainly the copts are leaving the country
i have a lot of coptic friends who are
now going to the states are now going to
canada or going to the uk to live over
there especially with young children
then they have you have their um
the so-called middle class people who
are trying to who can't live to europe
or to the states are leaving to other
arabic countries to work over there to
try their luck because it's really it's
such an easy thing to to talk about
daily living but it's hard for daily
living so this is why they're trying
their possibilities in other countries
so mainly young people are trying to
live the car not only young people
everybody is trying to leave the country
alan posner we did a program on egypt
last week as well and at the end i asked
for everyone everybody's assessment on
where they think things are going
whether they're optimistic or
pessimistic
things are moving so fast in egypt i'd
like to try the same thing again and
hear whether the answer's different i'll
tell you that after you all answer so
you're not influenced what would you say
looking at the short term and the longer
term
short term i'm pessimistic for democracy
but i'm optimistic for stability the
the they have the the military have the
situation basically under control
that's a good thing we're not going to
have a failed state
in the long term i'm pessimistic because
i think we'll just be back to the to the
pre-mubarak area uh era
thomas russell i'm also split for the
short term i would say it's a kind of
rollback the deep state as it's called
the security establishment the the
economic elite
will not let this country go to other
people so um democratization in the
short term i think is not very likely
but i i think that the
many egyptian people will learn from
this process as well and those who think
about what happened now and those who
are appalled by the violence of all
sides they will have learned something
and i i hope that for future generations
they will have another consciousness how
to deal with these things and maybe they
are more democratic than the people now
on the streets and so in the long term i
have some hope for egypt because the
people i think are able to adapt and to
change the mentality
yes
i agree with him that i think that it
needs time for egypt i'm optimistic
but as long as egypt has time and has
the young movement and people learned
from the past mistakes and i hope that
people will learn how to discuss with
each other and to accept other opinions
that one day they will get to one table
and discuss and work on a better egypt
so the
opinions last week were largely similar
pessimistic about the short term more
optimistic about the longer term i'd
like to ask all of you one last question
that has to do with basically uh alan
posner's statement that maybe the main
lesson of what we've seen in terms of
the west and its influence is that it
can't really do much that it is perhaps
more powerful powerless than ever
would you both also agree with that do
you think that we have essentially seen
the west also emerging into a new role
through this crisis thomas hassell i'm
not sure about this i mean i i tend to
be idealistic and i think um if germany
or the western world or europe let's say
would stick more to its values
and not always let the values slip away
by our economic and short-term strategic
interests it would be better for a lot
of countries in this world but what
would that mean
operationally
i think you have to stick to um to these
values and always not only rhetorically
but also in your actions um show that
you stick to these values and that would
really mean as i said before a
discussion about the whole region how we
deal with this region do we want to have
a conflict between the gulf era and
area and iran all the time shouldn't we
talk about israel and palestine much
more deeply than it's done now etc etc
and north africa is also a big topic i
mean we should learn from from past
mistakes and my opinion is that um
a democracy in all these countries would
be much more stable for and better for
us than what we have now alan you're
shaking your hands but let me head but
let me briefly go to yasmina and and
hear your thoughts on that well i
actually think that
the european union has to learn that you
can't implement the values that has
europe on the arabic countries that they
have to have the freedom to move and to
learn by themselves you can't tell them
how democracy is you can show them the
way but they have to go their own way
down into centers
i think we should learn more to to
follow our own interests and not talk
about values since we can't implement
them let's at least see where our
interests lie and that's stability
that's supporting israel that's not
having a thing blow up in our face
that's we ought to be more realist than
idealist
thank you very much that's a subject for
a whole other discussion which uh i will
look forward to having with you in
future thanks so much for being with us
today and thanks to all of you out there
for tuning in see you soon
you